alors françois boisrond bonsoir quand
j'étais petit c'est vrai que tu était
autiste et que tu n'arrivais pas à
parler tu arrivé à dessiner que c'était
un peu ta ta planche de salut
le lait ça tu peux enfin c'est plutôt
j'appellerai c'est un autisme doute pas
jusqu'à totalement études et ciné toile
[Applaudissements]
mais
tes fils de michel boisrond finalement
tu aurais pu faire dans le cinéma
facilement marche bien c'est peut-être
dû à mon autisme douche travaille pas
avec des gens dans ce que je viens de la
peinture ça décolle de passer mes
journées tout cela était bien plus mal
c'est les restes de retinne tu penses
quoi ton père en tant que cinéaste dont
georges j'aime beaucoup la mer aussi un
cinéaste ne sont félicités des films
ensemble
moi j'aime beaucoup c'est une championne
toute une période les premiers films
avec brigitte bardot tout cela vu sacrée
gamine 1955 premier film de ton père
c'était un des tout premiers succès de
brigitte bardot
je pense qu'ils sont assez vrai bonheur
dans ses films j'adore la garde à vue
toute relation avec la avec dario moreno
voulez vous danser alors l'arrivée de la
figuration libre sur le marché de l'art
c'est un coup de force total combas des
roses à blanchard vous allez démodé les
réalisent de l'époque les conceptuel le
pop art est un peu intello l'art brut
est un peu sociaux vous êtes vous êtes
arrivé comme ça à votre influence le
square grand matin aurait sauté un peu
enfin sa chance a changé beaucoup de
tout ce qui pourrait se passer dans
l'avant-garde et tristesse que nous
générons s'est jamais vraiment
intéressant comme ça on en fait on n'a
pas une idéologie d'avant-garde de
modernité comme ça c'est pas réellement
les choses qui m'intéressent pas je sais
j'ai plutôt envie d'être authentique que
moderne
tu as dit ma peinture ne cherche pas
être intelligente moi je suis un peintre
imbéciles ou marées vont nous sauter un
peu pourquoi devant je disais aussi que
j'ai pas avant de réfléchir c'était un
peu un justement de pas de chercher
comme ça un peu les les choses que
j'avais envie de faire sans forcément
savoir à quoi il faudrait correspondait
tout ça moi je sais quand j'étais aux
arts déco il y avait un profil fois
qu'il avait sorti il faut le peigné pas
s'il savait pas l'expliquer c'est un peu
effaré justement j'avais plutôt vendre
pas envie de vendre les choses que je
m'emballe barré
importante aux clientes heures ce n'est
pas ce qui est très intéressant et très
étonnant dans l' aventure de la
figuration libre
c'est finalement c'est au bal qui l'a
très bien dit d'ailleurs il a dit c'est
peut-être un des seuls mouvements
picturaux du xxème siècle qui a été dans
la grande presse avant d'être dans la
presse spécialisée c'est à dire que les
médias se sont très vite intéressé à
vous non ouais c'est vrai c'est le vin
ça tient aussi au fait que le pendant
vingt ans il ya eu comme ça une peinture
très un truc qu'on peut déjà assez comme
ça il faut parler très élitiste
apparemment pas du tout populaires 1 est
donc incertaine aujourd'hui contraint de
trouver les gens accueillis avec une
comme ça une peinture la prochaine c'est
simple tout simple c'est vrai qu'on
avait envie de ça passait à beaucoup de
gens et pas seulement partiellement
justement gens du milieu de la semaine
ce sera 80
un phénomène de votre territoire
les frères les poulains les musulmans
fumant bogeys salle tout s'était très
bien le devenir pas un train de baver
sur les cailloux comme ça tout ça je
vais appeler début et moi je
- ciel comme son côté un peu démagogique
que ça je pige que dalle trouve à cette
réussite c'est vrai c'était présenté
comme comme valeo va faire n'importe
quoi la crise n'a pas seulement été
entendu
c'est vrai que le fait de dire que la
sculpture enfin que de dallas pas les
retournant à la recherche du temps perdu
un peu n'importe quand on est dix ans
plus tard alors quel jugement du porte
surtout sur cette aventure cette
explosion de la figuration et justement
je pense que ça a été un peu plus un peu
superficiel on fait les choses ont été
vus comme ça que superficiellement et
bien peu trop bu
c est vrai qu un côté un peu un peu
facile et des matches et que si on en
face au vent les choses ont-elles ont
été présentés tous à élever ou la
figuration libre donc au début des
années 90 les ja c'est devenu
complètement sa charge chacun fait sa
peinture de la façon la plus la plus
personnelle de cinq ou six noms j'ai
fait notre série sur la pine sur la
télévision analamanga qu il n'y a vait
le paf
non justement chaucesse de cette
télévision enfin qu'on nomme le paf
paysage audiovisuel français s'appelait
salle paysage et celle de l'armement
dans le paysage c'est pas du tout un
regard critique ou sociologiques ou je
ne sais quoi sur la télévision c'est un
monde de regarder devant
les jeunes enfants d'observer un peu de
rendre cette matière de l'étrange ça et
je me suis aperçu que personne n'arrive
pas à vendre
beaucoup de banques qui sont comme ça
c'est avec une médiane de la télé vous
n'êtes jamais personne c'est vraiment
appliquée avant le concert ce qui est
drôle en matière de nationalité avec
nick qui a eu chez nahon la galerie
beaubourg c'est qu'effectivement il y
avait des certains écrans cryptée alors
c'était très pointis tout c'était
abstrait et c'est sur la maison s'est en
effet vous pouvez leur secours histoire
la nature attendent leur agrément
même si par exemple convaincant lapd a
dit eric de sa fin le fait un tableau
abstrait oui il ya dessous un beau
dossier n'entrait entre les plus
dangereux par le canal + on n'a pas le
coq ça fait un peu comme
l'impressionnisme à la maison comme ça
de chercher dans cette ex sénateur
s'était fait la vie sociale ça c'est le
pli fô c'était le paysage intime en
famille c'est un peu ça ça prenait un
peu les choses que j'avais prononcé sur
paris avec comme ça d'elle comme ça de
vue de parer à ces puits d'eau si début
de mon intérieur de bruit donc un aperçu
de l'épisode achats faisait un peu tous
les tous les paysages qui nous entourent
et combien de temps tu mets vous faire
un tableau devant ce jeu là quand j'ai
commencé je m'étais peut-être deux
heures un traitement je ne sais même pas
qui va le plus cher et ça me convient
par exemple nous savons au jeu pour une
somme moyenne 150 et les fraudes l'expo
elle est terminée la galerie beaubourg
montréal et voir août et à diana quand
même là non il y en a toujours
valérie bobos puis l'an prochain il y
aura une exposition à marseille au au
frac de marseille avec avec mes
camarades justement avec bombasse les
roses almarcha vous voyez toujours quand
même barroso toujours pas de problème
aucun problème il n'y a pas de guerre
des cas je vends ma foi on se dispute
souvent serait alors si on devait donner
une définition de toi que tu dirais quoi
finition de -25 une devise une épitaphe
une phrase qui résume moi j'en ai juste
voiture les gosses étaient si peu ouais
c'est ça ouais c'est une phrase que très
très bien savent que je suis un
compliqué à la recherche de la
simplicité
cette vache à lait pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de finale andy tube abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux